hello everyone and welcome to another
very exciting game from round five of
the Cote d'Ivoire rapid tournament in
Abidjan it's hard to say if I will ever
pronounce this properly a lot of you
have requested it already it's a
Egyptian Grandmaster Bassam Amina vs.
Hikaru Nakamura and aside from Magnus
Carlsen Nakamura is the strongest
opponent you can face in in Quakertown
formats so without further ado let's
check out the game it's well it's a long
game but with a lot of twists so I'm
sure you're gonna enjoy it with efore by
Bassam c5 by Nakamura Knight to f3 East
6 and now d3 not going for the open
Sicilian with d4 we have Knight to c6 g3
are preparing the Finca to the light
square bishop g6 Nakamura does the same
with Bishop g2 Bishop g7 and I mean just
castles with d6 by nakamura c3 now
preparing to push d4 Knight to f6 and
now comes a rook to e1 as Wendy 4 will
be pushed then the e4 pawn will also be
protected with castles by Nakamura D for
now and e 5 asking do you want to play a
really close game by advancing the pawn
to d5 or do you want to capture here I
mean it goes for D captures on c5 wheel
d captures on c5 and now Queen captures
on d8 I will look after sandy 8 so the
Queen's are off the board and Knights
the a3 this Knight is now coming either
to b5 to c4 or a or or c2 depending on
one black place and here this position
has been reached before nice to e8 is
the standard move here and Nakamura goes
for this 98 idea and here there is one
game in the database where nice the d2
was played but here we have Bush up to
f1 by I mean and it means that he
definitely came prepared it is the
strongest move recommended by the engine
as Black is preparing to defender the e5
pawn by playing f6 he wants the ring
maneuver this Bishop from this for a
moment close diagonal to this very
strong diagonal c4 and then of course
hitting the King so Nakamura continues
with its plan with f6 now strengthening
the center here with the ship to see for
this comes with check and now you don't
want to go to h8 then your
we'll be stuck in the center for a very
long time so came to f/8 and okay Bishop
to e3 the developing with tempo b6
defending and now we've disrupted d5
just you know make every move count so
you do have to react to this you can
either the defender will go should be
seven or with Bishop to d7 Nakamura
chooses Bishop to d7 butter up to b7
also works but he has Nakamura has a
different idea
we have Knights the b5 now and here it's
very hard to figure out a good way to
play this with black as black is you
know cramped in a bit you can play
something like f5 even though you want
to then Knight to g5 would be very
strong with this Bishop still controls
this diagonal Knight g5 to h7 would be
possible so Nakamura figures out a way
to develop with rook to b8 first getting
the rock out of this nasty diagonal so
now the knight can finally be moved
after a six is played we have a four now
and a six just getting that night back
with Knight 2 a 3 and Knights the e7 now
finally developing this night and well
the there's no longer a pin but should
be back to b3 and now finally Knight to
c6 back Nakamura most likely checking if
I mean it would repeat moves with Bishop
to d5 before figuring out a different
plan but I mean doesn't he finds a
different plan we have nice - D - the
plan is now just F for his bishops still
controlling this beautiful diagonal if
he wants to play f4 capture on e5 I play
rook rook f1 and create threats against
the black king we have Knight the c7
and now comes f-4s plan and here Bishop
to h6 so pinning this pawn you cannot
capture for the moment as Bishop
captures Bishop would happen and I mean
isn't ready to part with his dark square
Bishop we have King to g2 at least now
the capture on e3 will not come with
check if I mean ever decides to to push
f5 or to capture on e5 with Knight to a5
forcing the Bishop out of this a
wonderful diagonal because if Bishop
today - then the a four point is no
longer guarded and then Bishop capture
Sunday for would just happen
so Bishop to see - and now comes the
bishop
c6 putting his Bishop on this again very
nice diagonal with b4 by I mean knight
back to b7 and here comes Knight sorry
not this knight Knight d2 c for going
after the b6 pawn first he captures on
f4 we have G captures on f4 and now b5
by nakamura with captures captures and
now we have Knights to be six and
excellent square for the knight
preparing to capture here on c5 so you
do have to react to it with C capture
some b4 now comes the C capture some b4
and Knight to d6 so for the moment I
mean does have an excellent night and b6
guarded by the bishop here but it's also
you know you can't really move it back
can go night at four you can go Knights
e4 if you're gonna ID 5 we're gonna lose
the pawn so you do have to keep your
Bishop on e3 alive
first King to g3 getting the King out of
this nasty diagonal as well and also yet
another defender is brought to the f4
pawn but now comes Bishop captures on e4
with Bishop to c5 pinning the night here
and now just Bishop captures on c2 with
Knight captures and c2 and King to g8
getting the King out of this pin
Nakamura is preparing the bishop to f8
and now he's just gonna enjoy his extra
pawn with Knight the d4 by Amin and
night the c-4 now
for a moment you don't gain anything
good Knight to c6 you do create this
fork but just rub the d3 and well white
will lose the game Kim G - now just
capture and b6 you can capture capture
and then you have two nights for a rook
and of course a winning endgame
so after this nice to see four move we
have Knight captures on c4 with B
captures on c4 now nakamura creates a
passed pawn but I mean also has a past
be pawn we have Knight to c6
as now you want to create this fork but
then Nakamura can unfort if that is a is
a thing with rook the d3 check King to
f2 and now comes Luke to b7 not allowing
white the get hold of the 7th rank so
with f5
trying to create some weaknesses maybe
open up
the G file for the rooks to use but
Nakamura simply ignores it and starts
pushing his passport we have c3 as you
can see the bishop from h6 nicely
controls the C 1 that is the queening
square so it's already very dangerous
for white we have rook 3 do not allowing
the point to further advance because
once it reaches this light square then
the final square is a dark square and
that's gonna be a problem
Bishop to f8 now Nakamura wants the
trade off this dark square Bishop Bishop
captures we have King captures F
captures and g 6h captures and g6 and
now just rook to a5 preparing to to put
a look behind a passed pawn with rook to
c5 we've looked b6 attacking the knight
and now I mean defense both the knight
and prepares to well a guard the the
passed pawn from behind and here you
have to decide how to go about this the
best idea for Nakamura is rook to b5
just attack this rook any trade is of
course in favor of the person with the
pawn majority which is Nakamura in this
case so we would see something like 95
after the rooks are traded off rook
captures Knight captures just look back
to c4 and the Nakamura would just keep
enjoying his extra pawn but after this
rook to c5 move we have Knights - I ate
and now I mean finds an excellent tactic
he goes Knights to e7 goes after the g6
pawn nakamura defends at King to have 7
and not Knight d5 attacking the rook
here defending his pawn on b4 and also
creates a double attack against
Nakamura's past c3 pawn so you can't
control all of these threats rook to b7
and now comes b5 you you're gonna
capture this pawn there's no way of
defending it so why not improve a
deposition of your own pawn as well
we have Knight to d6 now bring yet
another attacker towards the the b5 pawn
and now just Knight captures on c3
grabbing that point and now Nakamura no
longer has his extra pawn with g5 King
to g2 and now comes King to g6 as
Nakamura no longer has an extra pawn you
can't really play this game on a pawn
advantage basis you have to know
create some other resources for for
attacking we've looked to be to now
putting Hills rook behind the past pawn
and Knight to f5
we have Knight to e4 and here comes
Knights the e3 check King to g1 and now
just rook to e7 the knight is attacked
so nice to f2 attacking the rook rook to
a3 and now comes look to see one I mean
doesn't want to allow any chances to a4
Nakamura he has to control the back rank
and now he will slowly but surely start
pushing his passport we have looked the
b7 Nakamura now has to lose activity for
his rook to prevent the past pawn from
advancing and now just h3 we have looked
to a5 attacking the past bone once again
and rook the c5 I mean just defends it
so as you can see
Nakamura's rooks turn around very
passive but it is a necessity if you
want to prevent this passport from from
going any further
we have Knight to f5 preparing to yet to
add another attacker to the pawn with 96
or d4 but whitey just prepares to defend
it once again in 94 with Knight to d4
with a triple attack against the pawn
but now just Knight to d6 and now the
pony's attacked three times and the
fender three times so you do have to
figure out a different plan worked at
least seven attacking the knight Knight
to c4 and now rook to a1 check here
Nakamura finds an excellent tactic which
would allow him for a drop if if I mean
fell for it we have king to f2 now comes
rook to h7 going after the pawn and now
I mean decides to give up this pawn he
pushes b6 and now can you capture the
pawn a fact of the matter is no you
can't I mean you could but it's a it's a
really it's a really difficult line
which maybe Nakamura saw maybe he didn't
but maybe he just wasn't satisfied with
it because if rook captures on h3 then
you get b7 and how do you how do you
stop the pass point here the problem is
after rook H to check King III rook
captures on b2 then you get night after
some b2 and now how do you prevent the
passport from queening maybe haven't
seen the interview after game if if an
interview was given but if you came to
this position and it's okay the Pony
screening there's no stopping it
but there
chili is a way to stop it you can go
rook III check white grabs the night and
now rugby three you go after the pawn
and the night and if you don't want to
lose the knight 94 then black grabs the
rook and you get this position where
Nakamura would have to pay to connect
the test points for a night which is
which is definitely you know a good good
basis to hold the draw but okay
perhaps he he was not interested in this
he still in it to win it so to say we
have rook to e8 by Nakamura preparing to
block the pass pawn would rook to b8 so
with b7 rook to b8 and now Knight to d6
now the night is defended the pawn is
defended by the night rook to see it is
the idea and it's going to be very
difficult to play this for Nakamura we
have rook captures on h3 now first look
the before forcing the Knights to move
with rook to h2 check King to f1 and now
rook to h1 check with King to g2 and now
rook to d1 defending the knight but rook
the c8 and here Nakamura creates a very
nice threat rook the D to check with
King to f1 and now comes Knight to f3
hanging the rook on b8 but the rook of
course cannot be captured if you capture
it then you get knowledge to check King
e1 now Knight of three check defends the
rook forces the King to move once again
I have one you just repeat kingi one
Knight f3 check you have to move back to
f1 or if you move to h1 then you're
getting checkmated as of course the
knight controls the G 1 square so after
Knight f3 with rook to b3
I mean of course is not interested in
falling for this trap and when he has
such an excellent position and now
Nakamura is forced to go into the
following endgame rook captures on b7
with Knight captures on b7 and now g4
defending the knight so opposite to the
to the winder that you've seen where
Nakamura had the option of going into an
end game where he would have to connect
the passed pawns for a knight now
Nakamura has to connect the test points
for a rook which is much different nice
the c5 just now bringing the night into
the game and again now the same idea
does not apply if Knight H to check just
King u 1 out of 3 check and of course
you just pick up the night so it's no
longer possible
captures here and then of course you
would be completely winning so after 95
with rook to c2 by Nakamura and now rook
to d3 King to f5 bringing the king into
the game and now comes Knight to b7
preparing 96 check and if rook captures
here then of course you will win back
the rope with a knife to d6 check and
the a d4 square is covered by the night
so you cannot attack the rook you would
have to move it captures and then again
you have this position where you have to
connected passed pawns for a rook which
is of course winning for white so we've
looked back to be two now comes 96 check
King to e6 and now rook to e8 check King
to be 7 and now comes look to e 2
offering a trade of rooks we have looked
to be 1 check King to f2 and now comes
Knight to e5 rook d2 d2 and we have King
to c6 just unpinning with Knights to e4
and now comes Luke the b3 so we're still
hoping to make use of his passed pawn
somehow we have looked the D sorry rook
to d6 check now attacking the King and
going after this pawn king to be 5 but
now rook captures on f6 Knights the d3
sorry knighted e3 which check King to g2
and the now comes rook to a3 we have
looked to f5 with check with King to see
for Nakamura brings the King deeper into
the position nice to f2 again offering a
trade and not nice to be for Nakamura of
course not interested in trades with
rook to e4 check King to c3 and now well
now comes the the killing idea now feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find it it's just a just a very nice
finisher so I'll give you a couple of
seconds while you well you you know
ponder on the position for those of you
who were able to do is congratulations
you were an excellent well winner of
winning and games and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
the movies rook to e3 check and now of
course you see that the King has to
defend the rook but it was actually in
this position on mu 85 that Nakamura
resigned the game after this check you
would have to go
be to to somehow try and defend the rook
but now you get 91 check King - eh - and
of course after the other rock lands
looked you have to check you have to
move and now
well you just pick up the rook and it's
all over and black would get checkmate
is fairly soon it's a forced checkmate
in five would with the best defense for
black but that's besides the point
sure that's a rookie three check
Nakamura resigned and an excellent
victory for Bassam Amin who who played a
great tournament he's the lowest rated
player here he's the wild card in this
first leg of the Grantchester
the only player rated below 2700 in this
tournament and of course he faces the
best players in the world but he managed
to defeat Hikaru Nakamura who is in
rapid well almost equal to Magnus
Carlsen himself and of course a Veselin
Topalov who is well deadly in any time
for mister given given he has a good day
but yeah now once again if you don't
remember the standings here they are we
can just check him out one more time
so constant first Nakamura second Maxime
holograph third and as you can see in
the last place Egyptian Grandmaster
bottom I mean like we said two victories
and in the one draw but definitely an
excellent tournament for for gaining
experience and well next time he faces
such elite players he will most likely
most likely do better that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Ralph Rix tariff karpea Julian
wall ELISA ELISA Berenbaum and Gary
Williams for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
in my previous videos you're thankful
for watching and I will see you soon if
you're watching the the Blitz section of
the cote d'ivoire which tournament in
Abidjan or feel free to you know suggest
games using hashtag suggestions I will
check them out as I don't think I will
be able to catch any live coverages yeah
I think I'll I will see soon and have an
excellent rest of your Saturday